hello everybody and welcome to today's
session on improvements to protein gel
electrophoresis both from a chemistry
and technology perspective now many of
you who are doing basic protein research
think that gel electrophoresis is a
pretty basic technique that has not
changed much over the years and though
that is true most continue to perform
these gels and relatively the same
manner they originally learned it in
college or in grad school or perhaps
from the labs in which they worked as
postdocs making small tweaks here and
there to these gels making small
improvements along the way so that they
can look at their downstream Western
blotting or gel staining a little bit
better and more improved however there
have been advancements over the years in
protein gels that have differed from the
moments a decade or so ago that made
protein gel electrophoresis much more
robust and also made a difference in
resolution and detection of your protein
separation and those are the small
improvements and large technological
gaps that we were wanting to touch upon
today in this session now in today's
session we're going to go through
several things broadly speaking we'll
talk about the types of protein gel
electrophoresis will highlight
specifically SDS page as the
electrophoresis system of choice we'll
go through the different buffer systems
that exist in the world of
electrophoresis as well as the gel
chemistry's that are out there we'll
also talk about these chemical and
technological improvements to gel
electrophoresis touching upon both self
casting gel systems as well as pre
casted gel systems as well as tasks a
pratices and improvements upon those as
well and finally concluding with the
types of choices and decisions and
conclusions that you can come from
understanding these improvements in gel
electrophoresis now the types of gel
electrophoresis are buried although
there is wonders predominantly most
popular than others as a quick overview
the basic polyacrylamide gel
electrophoresis or page gel separates
proteins by their native physical
properties this is sometimes often also
known as native page gel electrophoresis
the most common form however is SDS page
or sodium those SIL sulfate page
electrophoresis and this form
electrophoresis Eliza's proteins by
coating them with the uniform negative
charge disrupt disrupting the majority
of the non covalent bonds and reducing
the hydrophobicity SDS page treatment
largely removes differences between
proteins in both charge and conformation
making size the main determinant of the
electro phoretic mobility this mobility
is used to determine the approximate
molecular weights of the proteins with
reference to the mobility of the stained
protein standards that are in the same
exact gel in addition to SDS page and
typical native page there's also
reducing into nature at SDS page where
the addition of DDT or other additives
reduce disulfide bridges to achieve
better denaturing as a whole these are
the three major types of protein gel
electrophoresis now as an overview what
happens during SDS page well you first
begin with the protein itself you're
then going to add the SDS to that
protein yes yes then binds to the amino
acid residues and gives a uniform
negative charge as we mentioned and we
keep the protein then begins linearise
or denature once it's loaded onto the
gel the protein sample is loaded along
with the lane marker typically a set of
protein standards that denote the
different molecular weights of your
protein samples and then electric
current is applied where the negative
charge allows protein to migrate towards
the cathode end and separates the gel
based upon the electrophoresis
properties
now beyond choosing the type of gel
electrophoresis system that you want to
use choosing the right gel percentage
also helps in making sure that you have
good and solid protein gel separations
choosing the right gel percentage is
really a function of the protein size
that you're looking at if you have a
relatively simple single protein
application straight percentages are
great for
they provide estate separations of
protein sizes if you're looking for
proteins for example between the 4 to 40
kill Dalton range a 20% gel will do the
trick if you're looking for proteins
around the 10 to 70 range a 12 and a
half percent gel will also do the trick
however if your application calls for a
separation of a mixture of proteins then
the cranium gel percentage is best used
and depending on whether you need to see
very low molecular weights as part of
your separation or larger molecular
weights call your separations you choose
a different gel percentage gradient that
meets your needs at this time we'd like
to ask you a quick polling question and
regards to the type of gel chemistry you
commonly use in your applications you
use trace glycine gels this Cris gels or
trace acid gels we save the time right
now to answer this quick polling
question
okay so as related to that polling
question there are various different gel
chemistry's when it comes to SDS page
the most common form of putting gel
electrophoresis these chemistry's
include the most widely used Tris
glycine gel chemistry's for small medium
Pro in quotes and separations and tris
glycine uses traditional landline
buffers in its protein gel
electrophoresis in addition to Tris
license also mistress gel chemistry's
which also perform separations along a
small to medium protein range however
there other specialty chemistry's that
also exist
Tris acetate chemistry's which are
mentioned in the polls help with better
separation along larger molecular weight
proteins and try seeing gels allow for a
better separation along small molecular
weight proteins in addition to type of
chemistry there are also different types
of buffer systems both continuous and
discontinuous buffer systems in a
continuous buffer system it utilizes a
same buffer in the gel and the running
buffer although this is not as popular
as the discontinuous system it is still
useful but most commercially available
gels however use discontinuous buffer
systems and in a distant continuous
buffer system the two different gel
layers offer different pore sizes that
result in high resolution of separation
as an example of the type of
discontinues buffer systems let's take a
look at each one of them as it relates
to the three chemistry we had mentioned
earlier Chris glycine mistress and tris
acetate interest slicing chemistry's the
mixture includes glycine protein SDS
complex and chloride with the gel
operating pH of 9.5 and that's important
to note as we talked about improvements
to gel electrophoresis in the best fit
gel system it's a mixture of Messer mops
buffers protein SDS complexes and
chloride as well
however the running operating pH is 7.0
a neutral pH
interest acetate it's a mixture of try
seeing the protein SDS complex and
with the gel operating pH of 8.1 at this
time we like to take another opportunity
to ask the polling question to the
audience about your experience with your
gel electrophoresis when it comes to
resolution question is do you ever
experience smiling gels or poor bad
separation during electrophoresis yes or
no
thank you so let's take a look at each
one of these chemistry's one at a time
and specifically the two most popular
ones crystal icing and Mistress
chemistry's tris glycine utilizes the
traditional lammle system it is the most
widely used form of separating gels
using sds-page how great is highly
alkaline as operating pH as we have
mentioned earlier this is limited by
extending running times and gel
instability from the hydrolysis of high
chroma to comb acid in the alkaline
conditions and although triste glycine
is popular this kind of high pH in this
running operation may cause band
distortions a loss of resolution and
artifacts and bands due to protein
degradation alteration in run on the
flip side there is also the best risk
chemistry which operates underneath the
neutral pH condition this neutral pH
condition minimizes the protein
degradation and provides it the
following advantages over lammle systems
in improves the shelf life which extends
the shelf life to 16 months due to
improve just ability and also due to the
neutral pH it can create sharper band
resolutions and more accurate results as
an example of what this looks like this
particular dataset compares on the left
hand side the Invitrogen volt gel which
is a BIST Tris chemistry gel to a
traditional crystallizing gel on the
right hand side and in it
various different proteins have been
loaded similar proteins for you to
fridge Lane as you can see from the left
hand side of the distress bolt gel the
bands are relatively sharp and clean on
the right hand side but risk icing gels
the bands are a little bit more
separated and different degradation
events have occurred now oftentimes a
protein degradation that happens with
non neutral pH chemistry's
are not as dramatic as an example we
show here more often than not it shows
up in the few stands or smeared bands
and if you have ever experienced those
fatigue or
using at-risk lice and gel it could be
due to the new to the high pH of at-risk
ice Angele and what happened there is
that the protein degradation event
occurred in varying degrees and those
varying degrees of degradation had been
seared and separated out as the gel
progressed now as far as options beyond
chemistry and buffer conditions there is
also a choice between self casting
options and pre cast gel options and the
materials that are needed for both are
different mainly because of the amount
of warmth that goes into each one with
the self casting gel option you'll need
on only a casting apparatus acrylamide
the team ed ApS staffing resolving
buffers gel running buffers as well as a
running taint
you also need the time to be able to
perform the cell cast itself the pros of
course are that you get a fresh gel each
time which is advantageous however it is
a lot of time and effort there's casting
apparatus failures just lysine is the
predominant main choice in chemistry and
single percentages are typically the
only way the only types of gels and you
can cast inconsistency in the gel casts
can also result in resolution
inconsistencies on the flip side with
precast gel options you simply need the
pre cast gel product running buffers and
the gel tank the pros of precast gel
product is it's more consistent results
and sharper bands due to consistent
manufacturing practices of the companies
that offer them and the choice of
different chemistry's also exists not
only in straight percentages but also in
grading percentages however there is a
con which is a higher consumable cost
for the researcher what we like to do
now is to ask another polling question
to the audience as it relates to the
type of gels that you typically do do
you perform self casting gels or you
perform pre cast gels
now you may be considering that self
casting gels is a typical process that
you would go undergo protein
electrophoresis or pre cast just may be
your typical process but we want to make
sure that you understand that there have
been made improvements made to build
self casting gels and pretest gels and
we'll go into each one of them now
including the pod self casting gels
begins with the primary issues that a
user could potentially see when passing
their own gels and a primary issue that
most customers see is that the casting
apparatus fails and this exhibited in
either leaking or the breaking of the
apparatus itself the glass plates which
are utilized in the systems often chip
or crack which can lead to leaks the
foam inserts or the manner in which the
gel plates are seal may deteriorate over
time causing leaks and this all results
in a waste of effort and time in exhibit
exemplified in to be pouring of a new
gel now our nitrogen sure cast hand
caste system which recently came out
this year exhibits a couple of features
that help solve for these problems
number one it has a more durable
reusable glass plate it's sticker and
more damage resistant than what current
suppliers offer hitting upon one of the
major needs that the customers have when
it comes to be pouring gels it's up to
twenty times more durable in that
respect also it's a hundred percent deep
free due to the wide silicone
face-to-face ceiling method that we've
employed which provides even pressure
seals across all three sides of the
plate and increases seal durability over
time meaning to less deterioration and
therefore fewer leaks in addition to the
apparatus improvements his shirt cast
hand cast reagents are all stored at
room temperature which can provide
additional benefits and that applies to
not only the team at APs and both
stacking and resolving buffers but can
also apply to the 40% of Crillon lab
which is quite unique why is this better
you may ask well it begins
with making sure that all the casting
agents are at the same temperature when
you begin casting your gels with all the
reagents at the same room temperature
the temperature effects and
polymerization rates are reduced having
everything at the same temperature means
you won't have to spend time bringing
all the reagents up to the same
temperature you need to begin casting
your gels a lot sooner
also with everything at four degrees
Celsius of room temperature easier and
safer storage is is achievable without
having to bring everything up to the
same temperature at this highly like to
ask another polling question to the
audience do you wish you could have
loaded more samples into your gels yes
or no
in addition to self casting improvements
there have also been improvements to
precast gel options and related to the
previous polling questions when the
primary customer needs when it comes to
precast gels is it need to load more
samples into their wells oftentimes
customers make a choice there between
the thickness of the gel itself either
1.0 millimeter moving to 1.5 millimeter
and this is a need for customers
especially those performing gel
electrophoresis on low abundance protein
samples or perhaps antibodies that have
a poor or weak affinity and therefore
resulting in poor protein signal at the
back end Western blot poor gel
resolution can also be a primary issue
with customers especially those
utilizing traditional lammle buffer
conditions with the initiative melbeck
swedge Electress glycine gels we try to
solve for some of those problems first
namely we have a proprietary wedge 12
shaped gel which allows you to load up
to sixty microliters of sample per well
this well as exhibited by the image on
the right is in a triangular wedge shape
well and available in these particular
mini gels in addition the prevail
resolution and quality has been improved
as well to minimize the smiling effects
and distortion that you typically see
with tris glycine gels in this data set
we try to explain what exactly it means
to have a wedge well when it comes to
your protein gel separation results on
the left hand side is Deneuve ex-wife
ultra slicing ten world gels along with
the various different volumes of sample
loaded into each well on the right hand
side is a typical Tris Kaizen gel from
competing supplier loaded with the same
sample volumes of 20 30 40 50 and 60
microliters as you can see with the
novak's wedge ultra slicing gel even at
60 microliters skipping wells in between
samples you do not see spillover in the
separation of the gel itself however on
typical standard well crystallizing gels
you see spillover effects happening in
and around the 50 micro litre loading
volume and the
60 micro litre bottle loading bargaining
thus showing that the milled extra
slicing wedge water gel can load all the
way up to 60 microliters in a tell model
format without spilled over into
subsequent lanes from a resolution
perspective in dome extra-spicy wedge
well gel has been shown to have
minimized smiling distortion effects
compared to other suppliers
crystallizing gels as exhibited here in
this dataset in addition to providing
improvements due to larger load volumes
there has also been improvements that
have made due to ban resolutions as a
result of gel chemistry's as we had
mentioned earlier in the presentation as
well as improvements on gel running
times and the particular product that
from our company that we want to be able
to exhibit today is the mutagen at Boalt
mistress gels it's neutral pH mistress
chemistry preserved the protein
integrity with the neutral pH as we had
mentioned and offers a unique buffer
formulation that illuminates the smiles
and poor resolution seen on traditional
tryst license in addition the bolt
mistress gels also contain the wedged
well shaped wells easily allowing for up
to sixty microliters of sample load
volume in a 10 watt format but in
addition to these two features the bolt
gel can also be run in as quickly as 22
minutes at 200 volts here similarly to
the Nomex white wall gel we loaded 40 50
55 60 and even up to 70 microliters of
sample in a 10 watt gel as compared to
competitors typical lunch typical
standard well gel going up to 40
microliters and similarly to the wedge
well shape we do not see spillover in
the adjacent lanes for the bolt gel
unlike standard well gels we do see
spillover that's showing that the bolt
gel can can contain up to 60 or more
microliters of rode volume
here's the same piece of data that we
showed earlier
exemplifying the difference between the
bitterest neutral ph gel chemistry
versus a traditional crystallizing gel
chemistry the bolt mistress gel
chemistry with the neutral pH minimizes
protein degradation Zin run leading to
more sharp and better resolutions in
your gel electrophoresis in this data
set we perform the Western blot using
the bulk gel on the top and a
competitor's Chris Tyson gel and the
typical gel stain on the bottom and a
competitor's Chris Tyson gel on the
bottom as well and this again
exemplifies how a mistress neutral pH
along with the mutagen manufacturing
process provides a much more consistent
and publishable result with minimize
smiling distortions in the bands of the
gel electrophoresis furthermore
improving upon precaster options we also
have the ambition new page
no vex mistress protein gel also
including the neutral pH gel chemistry
which preserves protein integrity with
the neutral pH as well as fast sharp
band resolution runs in as little as 30
minutes at 200 volts here is a piece of
data comparing on the left the new page
mistress gel with the supplier's tryst
icing gel again showing that better
resolution and better publishable band
results can be achieved with the
mistress neutral pH chemistry's so in
summary for precast options we presented
today the triskele icing no vex wedge
well and tris glycine options both
mistress and you pinch mistress options
and for their self casting Jon option we
have been booshed ensure cast hand cast
apparatus as well as the shirt cast hand
cast reagents in addition to these
particular gel option we also offer
Triss acetate options for larger
molecular weight separations try scene
options for low molecular weight
separations and various other chemistry
such as a native page for typical page
electrophoresis in addition to the
provements on gel electrophoresis gels
there are also been improvements on
protein gel electrophoresis tank
apparatuses primary user issues for
standard gen tanks include a
back-to-back design which makes it
difficult to load samples easily without
turning the tank around wasted gel
running buffers for those who want to
run a single gel on their tank
apparatuses difficulties in seeing the
gel progression in the latter
progression in run do the clarity of the
plastic utilized and difficult to judge
the buffer fill volumes when the tank
when the tank is floral in that capacity
the envisioned mini gel tank makes
subtle yet significant improvements to
the user experience when it comes to gel
apparatus we have simultaneous
visualization of both gels in a
streamlined side-by-side tank
configuration we allow for easy sample
loading through a forward-facing well
configuration less running buffer is
required especially when you're running
only a single gel you can load only one
chamber at a time if you wish the white
background on the tank allows for easy
and simple monitoring of the pre stain
ladders and standard loaded onto the gel
and spilled over chambers on the edges
allow for consistent and precise buffer
fill lines at this time we would like to
ask an additional polling question to
the audience how fast would you ideally
like your gels to run under 30 minutes
between 30 and 60 minutes or over 60
minutes
as a summary of running conditions on
the mini jell tanker we like to exhibit
a couple of things the note both the
bolt and new page mistress chemistry
gels can run in under 60 minutes with
the bolt gel running underneath mess
running buffer conditions as low as 20
to 22 minutes
underneath the mobs running condition
and as low as 35 minutes the new page
mistress chemistry's hid run as low as
30 minutes at 200 bolts utilizing a mess
running buffer and as low as 42 minutes
utilizing the mobs running buffer
typical triskele icing gels can run
anywhere between 25 to 40 minutes or an
hour and hour and a half plus depending
on the nature or native state running
condition
typical tris acetate gels can run
between 50 to 100 minutes again
depending on the nature or native state
running conditions as a summary to
choose which gel type is best for you
it's important to understand whether or
not you want to run nature the nature
rust conditions or native running
conditions in the de natured separation
your first choice is choose between
molecular weight sizes we had mentioned
earlier on that if you're looking at of
low molecular weight protein and you
want to resolve in among other low
molecular weight proteins a try some gel
would be your best choice if however
you're looking at a higher molecular
weight protein mix those about 200 kilo
daltons buttress acid a gel would be the
best gel of choice those who are looking
at proteins in the middle or the most
broad range of molecular weights between
20 and 200 kilonewtons a typical Tris
glycine or distress gel would be a good
would be your shelf choice but between
the two understanding how much sample
you want the load onto your gel could
make a difference in your ultimate
result and choosing a legible shape gel
either the Novus wedge long gel from a
nitrogen or the bolt ledge while gel
will allow you to load up to 60
microliters of brawlin name also if your
results result if your gel results
result in smearing or smiling effects
choosing abyss Tris neutral pH chemistry
could minimize those results as well in
a native separation you will be able to
choose between molecular weights
isoelectric points and protease activity
as your predominant choices of protein
gels so the key takeaways today from the
session is that the most widely used
chemistry is tryst Ising because it has
no special running buffers however it
can lead to certain degradation of
proteins in running that is where a
neutral pH system such as the best Tris
chemistry's were allowed to minimize no
protein degradation improve gel results
and also improve running times high
sample load volumes can also be achieved
using traditional Christian chemistry's
such as the mill Bex wedge roll Chris
Tyson gels or mistress gel chemistry
with the bolt mistress plus gels if
you'd like to learn more about protein
electrophoresis or downstream Western
detection or transfer we have various
technical handbooks at your disposal for
both separate transfer and detect of the
Western work for the various URLs are
provided here and are free for you to be
able download and that concludes this
session today on protein gel
electrophoresis improvements there are
any questions we'll go ahead and open it
up for Q&A session thank you
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to run our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and our first
question is if you see defuse bands in
the stain is it always due to the gel
chemistry so the answer to that is no
although we've shown today during the
presentation that gel chemistry's can
lead to better results we had shown the
difference between the depredations and
crystal ice and gels versus mistress
gels gel chemistry is not the only
reason why you would see a diffuse ban
on a gel stain for example oftentimes
the most common reason is the amount of
protein that's actually loaded into the
gel itself sometimes loading too much
protein can lead to smearing or fat
bands that will not resolve well in a
protein gel and although other times
most researchers and users do not know
how much actual protein is in their
sample if they do see a rather diffused
band show up in in a gel chemistry that
they're used to using and have good
separations typically reducing the
amount of protein sample loaded onto the
gel can solve for that especially if you
already have a very well-defined signal
this could actually sharpen up your gel
results there was a difference in
running times between mess and mops for
the mistress gels what's the difference
there so yes yes there was a difference
there between vests and mops and you saw
it in both the bulk gels the NewPage
gels and
and and and there were quite not quite
significant but there were at least a
few 10 minutes here and there
I believe the bolt gels you can run the
mess running buffer you know those 22
minutes versus 35 minutes of mops with
the new page gel as you can run that gel
as low as 30 minutes
I believe this though is 42 minutes with
the mops typically this decision between
mess and mops comes down to the
molecular weight of the protein itself
mops will slow down that gel run and by
slowing down the gel run it achieves
better separation at the mid to large
molecular weight range mess is much
better for smaller molecular weight
proteins and so that's typically the
difference in choice when users have to
decide between a mess or box running
buffer
our the which will gels all sixteen
microliter well capacity I know they're
there they are not we had shown examples
of data today that had the sixty
microliter examples set at the ten well
capacity and so the maximum load
capacity for ten well gels are sixty
microliters however if you are using
larger number of wells such as a twelve
well or fifteen well mini gel just from
common sense rise the well size is going
to be a lot smaller from the width to
width perspective and so you're gonna
have a lower maximum roading volume
however despite the fact that that
happens at the twelve to fifteen well
gel it's still a larger load volume
compared to a standard well gel itself
for example for the twelve load gel the
maximum loading capacity of a wedge well
is forty five microliters and if you
compare that to a standard capacity of
about twenty-five microliters for a one
millimeter thickness gel or 37
microliters for a 1.5 millimeter gel a
forty-five micro litre capacity on a one
millimeter jail for twelve well Joe is
still much larger so even though it's
much smaller for larger number wells
it still is much larger than a standard
well gel
why did the land meet risk lysine gels
have a short shelf life of about three
months so the typical risk lysine gel if
you make it yourself definitely has a
short shelf life abroad trip about three
months there have been various different
additives added to commercially made
crystal ice and gels allowed to be a lot
longer in shelf life but not as long as
a mistress neutral pH gel and and that's
exactly the main reasons why it's the pH
of the chemistry itself and the basic pH
levels that chrome eyes slowly
hydrolyzes and formed the acrylic acid
over time which interferes with the
proper of protein separation as we had
seen in the actual gel results but this
also leads to a much this instability
over time allows for a much lower shelf
life if you were to make it yourself as
a fresh gel obviously but additives have
been created to be able to extend the
shelf life of traditional land intro
sizing gels and obex wedge well
crystallizing gels for example have a 12
month shelf life so not all
crystallizing gels have a short shelf
life especially but more and more
especially than ones that we make on
your own
okay we have time for one last question
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed after the presentation
I am interested in peptide separation
short lengths of molecular weights of
800 Dalton's what gel is suitable for
this so as we had mentioned in the
presentation your gel choice can be
locally dependent so for small short
lengths of molecular weights such as
that where it's 800 Dalton's you may
want to try to try some gel chemistry
which allows for the separation of the
lower low molecular weight proteins to
be at a larger percentage of the total
gel layer so that allows you to separate
out the lowland little weights better so
that you can see sharper resolutions
between these local ways whereas in a
standard broad molecular weight gel such
as a tryst glycine gel or this Tris gel
the low and high end killo Dalton on
molecular proteins will be much more
compact in its run and it's in its
resolution so it's a little bit harder
for you to resolve out various different
peptides of small molecular weight
length similarly with the higher
molecular weight proteins we recommended
at risk acetate gel chemistry because
what it will do is it will actually
spread out the high molecular weights
along a larger percentage of the gel so
you actually are able to resolve better
higher molecular weight proteins above
200 Kelvin so for smaller short lengths
as the question that asks the try some
gel is the best for larger molecular
weights we recommend you Tris acetate
and for every body that's in between a
standard risk lysine or mistress gel
will do the trick
I would like to once again thank June MA
for his presentation do you have any
final comments we appreciate you guys
coming on to the event and we hope you
enjoy the rest of the day's events thank
you I would also like to thank our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 28th 2017 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to Ford that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye